14h28 il hier après midi bordeaux
mérignac
le prototype du falcon 2000 roule sur la
piste guy michaud maurouard pilote
d'essai tire le manche à lui et c'est le
premier décollage du nouvel avion
d'affaires de dassault
1h15 de vol au dessus du médoc jusqu'aux
gorges du verdon
rien à redire le comportement de
l'appareil a été étonnamment conforme
aux calculs des ingénieurs biréacteur le
falcon 2000 pourra transporter
confortablement huit passagers sur des
étapes de 5500 kilomètres parcourus à
900 km heure cet avion vole plus haut
que les avions des compagnies
commerciales et pour lui les routes
aériennes ne sont pas près d'être
embouteillée pour ce premier équipage
jean puggy mito maurouard la
certification en vol ne devrait pas
poser de problème particulier chez
dassault les affaires reprennent
50 options déjà été prise par une
dizaine de pays
premières livraisons prévues début 95